bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors un an après sa
réélection à la répression d'un vaste
mouvement de contestation
alexandre loukachenko est donc toujours
l'homme fort de la biélorussie malgré la
défiance d'une partie de la population
et les sanctions américaines et
européennes comment l'expliquez vous
je crois que l'explication est toute
simple c'est à dire que nous avons en
occident une vue qui est légèrement
poussé sur la biélorussie certes c'est
un mouvement très très fort une
contestation
elle est inutile de le nier ça se voit
c'est très clair en revanche il y a un
support très important pour le cash and
co parce que là la biélorussie c'est
essentiellement un pays de campagne et
dans les campagnes le cash and co est
toujours très populaire parce que c'est
l'homme fort c'est celui qui garantit
l'indépendance c'est celui qui flatte le
peuple des campagnes en particulier dans
le sens qu'il faut et donc lorsque ici
on voit que l'élection présidentielle
était faussé oui elle était fou c'est
parce que jamais le cachet qu'on aurait
pu être élu avec 80 % des voix mais en
revanche il aurait été élu avec 57 60 on
ne sait pas mais il aurait certainement
été élu il n'avait pas besoin réellement
de tricher et c'est cette triche idiote
qui est dû à son ego parce qu'il tenait
absolument à être élu avec 80 % comme
des années précédentes qui a créé
véritablement le problème
alexandre loukachenko ne cesse de
qualifier à ses détracteurs de suppôt de
l'occident qui veulent selon lui
renversé à son gouvernement pour pouvoir
ensuite s'en prendre à moscou réa
vladimir poutine est ce que ces
accusations sont crédibles selon vous
ces accusations ne sont pas vraiment
crédible mais elles ont tout de même un
fond de vérité le fond de vérité c'est
qu'effectivement
actuellement l'opposition
sion se trouvent essentiellement en eksi
en exil en lituanie en pologne et donc à
l'étranger et en union européenne que
par ailleurs ces mouvements sont
soutenus très largement par les états
unis par des fondations et par l'union
européenne elle-même et donc ça ça crée
une suspicion est évidente pour les
autorités de minsk mais il ya une autre
opposition qui elle est plutôt favorable
à moscou et qui se trouve une certaine
manière par réaliser non pas l'étranger
mais en prison par exemple le principal
opposant celui qui aurait pu gagner
l'élection présidentielle
éventuellement de l'année dernière qui
est victor babarit qu il est plutôt
proche de moscou mais il est en prison
et condamné pour 4 à 14 ans dernièrement
début juillet il a été condamné à 14 ans
de camp à régime sévère donc si vous
voulez l'opposition n'est pas unie loin
de là mais en plus
lukashenko peut se servir des uns contre
les autres ce donc ce qu'elle ne
maîtrise pas réellement à l'intérieur
sont en prison ce don qu'il n'a pas
grand chose à faire parce que de toute
façon ils n'ont pas une grande influence
à l'intérieur du pays c'est à dire
l'opposition en exil et bien c'est un
mal que l'on peut justement dénoncée en
étant comme étant piloté par l'occident
donc en fait de la situation de le
cacher quoi malgré les apparences est
relativement stable sur le front de
l'opposition là où il est moins stable
c'est sur le front international parce
que là il faut qu'il gère avec d'un côté
l'union européenne qui était son
partenaire il n'y a pas encore longtemps
de la rue 6 et tous nos fonds
partenaires mais on sent bien que la
dîme et routine soutien loukachenko
comme la corde soutient le pendu et
justement il vous l'évoquez ans la
russie qui est la principale ali et de
la biélorussie mais comment se manifeste
ce soutien à minsk
ont le soutien à mills que se manifeste
essentiellement d'un point de vue
économique il est évident aujourd'hui
que sans l'aide de moscou la biélorussie
serait dans une situation bien moins
favorable qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
en substance la russie consentent des
prix très bas sur l'énergie le pour
permettre le développement de l'économie
biélorusse une partie de cette énergie
du gaz du pétrole de l'électricité
est vendue à des pays tiers mais aux
prix mondiaux et c'est donc cette
différence qui permet au budget de la
biélorussie d'être
excédentaire et de permettre notamment
des plans sociaux qui permettent
d'acheter la la tranquillité du peuple
sans cette aide
la biélorussie serait vraiment dans une
mauvaise position simplement aujourd'hui
à la suite de l'incident du de l'avion
de ryanair étaient obligés contraint
d'atterrir à minsk ce qui a permis
l'arrestation de l'opposant protosevich
l'union européenne a décrété des
sanctions
structurel c'est-à-dire qu'elles
touchent directement l'économie et non
pas seulement quelques entreprises ou
quelques personnalités du
[Musique]
proche de loukachenko hélas ces
sanctions elle concerne les flux
d'énergie elle concerne la potasse la
biélorussie est l'un des premiers
exportateurs de potasse aulas des côtes
ont été introduits il est beaucoup plus
difficile pour la biélorussie d'accéder
aux financements occidentaux européens
les entreprises européennes
ces sanctions pierre laurent est ce
qu'elles peuvent peser sur le
gouvernement biélorusse voir le
déstabiliser non elles ne peuvent pas le
déstabiliser parce que comme je disais
tout à l'heure il est il est un des
probables dans la mesure où
la seule chose qui peut se passer c'est
que ça va rapprocher encore plus la
biélorussie de la russie le seul espoir
de la biélorussie dans ce complexe alors
que la biélorussie était toujours
partisane d'une politique
multivectorielle c'est à dire tourner
vers la russie mais tournaient également
vers l'europe est là maintenant on ne
peut plus se tourner vers la russie donc
ça ne va pas déstabiliser lukashenko
d'autant plus qu'il a promis une réforme
constitutionnelle
l'année prochaine et que donc on va voir
bien on va bien voir ce qui se passe
mais de toute manière les liens avec la
russie
seront maintenus corps comme il le
disait très bien le cas chaîne pour dans
l'extrait que nous avons vu la russie
n'a pas besoin d'une nouvelle zone de
tension à gérer donc la russie va
continuer à soutenir lukashenko mais je
le répète d'une manière bon il sera
obligé de passer selon sur certaines
conditions sinon on le lâche pas
pierre-laurent merci pour cet éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et spécialiste de l'urss